we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p you can call
that number absolutely any time of day
let's take a listen to the voicemail
that i have here for you uh very very
interesting came in during the vacation
actually and it is something i want to
address take a listen hey david its
george again i was just wondering what
you think about amy schumer's bud light
commercial with seth rogen and uh
whether you think the 77 cents to a
man's dollar is a myth or not warmest
regards yeah uh I know you're trying to
catch me and then accuse me of being
some kind of social justice warrior or
whatever we've extensively researched
the gender pay gap 77 cents to the
dollar is not the right number the right
number is that women for the same work
earn somewhere around 90 cents for every
dollar a man makes and what we've
determined is that some part of that 10
cent difference uh can be attributed to
gender discrimination exactly how much
of it is very difficult to measure but
no I don't subscribe to the 77 cents on
the dollar thing because it's
demonstrably untrue and we've explained
that many many times on the bonus show
today Elon Musk plans to get humans to
Mars in six years denmark capitalizing
on the stop food waste movement and we
will talk about a new discovery when it
comes to crohn's disease david
pakman.com slash membership is the one
place to sign up to get instant access
to the bonus show